The next step is going to be to distribute the 3 to both terms over here on the
left side, and leave the right side the same as it was. And then, I just need to
collect all of my variables on one side and all of my constants on the other
side. And we get a final answer of x equals 22. In all the problems we've done
so far, it just so happened that it was most convenient for us to end up with
variables on the left side and constants on the right side. However, that's not
necessary. I could very easily have decided that I wanted my variables on the
right side, instead of the left side. And started out here by subtracting 3x
from both sides. I would have just had, eventually, to divide by a negative
number. And that's not always my favorite thing to do. But in the future, feel
free to put the constants and the variables on either side of the equation.
Whatever is easiest for you.